[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the former nfl quarterback pro football
talk
live co-host and a member of football
night in america chris sims back with us
let's start with tay sim hill did you
get the sense
that the media was rooting against
taysom hill
in this game against atlanta oh i don't
know if i got the sense they were
rooting against him
um maybe people were surprised one that
jameis winston didn't get
the nod to be the starter uh i i mean
i know what you're saying it does seem
to be a sense out there
that like oh taysom hill can't be a
quarterback and he hasn't played enough
and there is that element
but man the position he was in yesterday
it it was choppy it didn't look great
early
but i was pretty impressed for a guy who
hasn't played snaps in the nfl as a
starting quarterback yet and what he did
and kind of how he managed the game and
slowly but surely made some plays to go
along with it
do you think he's a starting quarterback
in the nfl
i uh i'd like to see more before i throw
that in there and the first thing is dan
like i think you'd be on board with this
if sean payton thinks he does
then i it's hard for me not to think
that too i mean he's
damn good coach he's obviously one of
the best offensive minds we've had in
football over the last 20 years
he's got all the skills and
everything there to be a starting
quarterback you could see the arm is
real
you know he does have nice patience and
poise in the pocket
you know through a lot of nice
intermediate throws to michael thomas
and doing that type of stuff and then
his scrambling ability
so it might not look like drew brees or
anything like that but
yeah i think his skill set and the way
he throws the football and it seems like
his mental demeanor
lends him to being a potential starting
quarterback and a good one at that
my only curiosity with this was the uh
sean payton this great offensive minded
head coach saying
i need to see what i have in taysom hill
yeah like you had to wait to put him in
a real game as a starting quarterback to
see what you had with a 30 year old that
that was the only thing that was
surprising about
uh that decision i i agreed i mean
that's where i wasn't sure if he would
actually pull the trigger and make that
move to just go man we're in the thick
of things here
we could be the number one seed in the
nfc i don't think
number one seed benefits any team more
than the new orleans saints
and them being at home in that dome drew
brees inside
all of those things so that's where i
wasn't sure either dan
but you know obviously he felt like at
least he was
mentally ready for the challenge to a
degree to step
up and understanding the offense and
doing all of that
and i think that in a lot of ways i bet
you sean payton liked the
challenge of let me see how i can
diversify my offense what other elements
can i add here
and really in the perfect world you'd
hopefully hopefully you know do it
towards the playoffs end of the year
they could almost
merge both offenses together to get a
little the best out of both worlds and
make taysom hill a legitimate part of
the offense because he's a pretty
skilled guy
i know we're looking at the end result
with joe burrow he
was what over 400 attempts they were
always behind
um he was on pace to have at least you
know be sacked 50 times
was the bengals approach irresponsible
with joe burrow a rookie throwing the
ball that many times behind an offensive
line that was sort of makeshift
well i had argued that there was weeks
where i really talked about on pro
football talk with florio and things
like that that they better be careful
that they were flirting with danger and
really their number one objection uh you
know odd
objective for the year would be yeah get
joe burrow
better and comfortable but don't get him
hurt
that was they were almost go hand in
hand and man he went through a year of
i mean really towing the line of like
you said big
shots i mean crazy big shots not just
like oh he got beat up but like
a few weeks where we're going oh my gosh
like is he gonna get up i mean there was
a lot of that
and to me that did bother me um i know
they're trying to win a football game
but i do think with where they at in
their franchise and the fact that he is
their franchise
yeah there should have been a little bit
more emphasis on
let's protect him yeah we might look a
little bit uglier but
we're at least going to be healthy going
into 2021 with a really damn good
quarterback
i thought that the dolphins brian flores
just said i can't leave tua out there he
was sacked six times the
last one was looked like he landed a
little awkwardly it was
you know lower leg um you know it felt
like he was struggling a little bit but
that might have been just
self-preservation to take him out
bringing in ryan fitzpatrick
yeah i think so you know it was um it
was
vic fangio's a good defensive mind it
did look like
you know and again i'll be tempted to
watch the film and really get the
answers but you know yes under pressure
in the pocket but also a lot of plays
where i think you saw it the same way
where he's in the pocket
it's pretty good and he doesn't want to
throw
nobody's open he's not sure what he's
looking at whatever that reason may be
obviously the offense wasn't cooking all
cylinders and this is where
you know we still have to see more of
chua this was the first game where
it was kind of like hey the special
teams the defense
they're not they're not dominating today
you're gonna have to make some plays and
the bootlegs and just the one-on-one
fade balls aren't gonna be there
and you know now we'll see as we go
forward if tua can take that next you
know
step up in his level of development and
say hey when the team's not doing good
don't worry guys get on my left shoulder
and i'll i'll throw the ball around the
lot and make things happen
chris sims pro football talk live
co-host on peacock
you had a top ten list was that last
week and ben roethlisberger was not on
your
top 10 quarterback list right yeah
feedback did you did you hear from
steeler fans
well yeah i did i heard a lot from the
steelers fans i
i had to like stop looking at my social
media i had people from pittsburgh
calling me
you know as far as the radio stations
wanting to get me on there have big
ben's playing awesome there's no doubt
about that there's a lot of damn good
quarterbacks in football right now
i would argue there's not a quarterback
problem you've heard me say this before
there's an offensive coordinator problem
there's not a quarterback problem big
ben is amazing
but i just think the thing i have dan
where i just left him out
right is he's on a really good team
we know he's got great weapons and they
got a defense that's unbelievable
you know a lot of these other
quarterbacks i got in the top ten the
game
is dictated by the quarterback their
team is built around that
what he can do they apply pressures uh
pressure on team through the quarterback
with pittsburgh just like you saw
yesterday yeah the end result
looked good but hey there's been some
underwhelming performances
he has the defense to sit there and
create plays and he can take his time
oh wait so it looks ugly and then they
get a feel in the third quarter what
you're doing and he hit some big plays
and all that
it's amazing i'm not trying to
disrespect him i have a ton of respect
for him but no i don't think he's one of
the 10 best in the game right now
but i think he's in the top five mvp
though because probably i looked at the
steelers and i said if ben is healthy
they're the most
dangerous intriguing team going into
this season i just didn't know and still
don't know if ben can stay healthy the
entire year
but everything else is there for them to
be a legitimate super bowl contender
which is it sounds strange he's not in
your top ten but he might be in your top
five mvp
well yeah well this is the this is the
world we're in i mean the mvp is
it's like the heisman she's like who's
the best quarterback on the best team
and that's what we're going to give it
to and that's all it comes down to
so it's it's i understand that talk
he's doing a great job of managing
football games he hasn't made a lot of
mistakes i mean he's really doing
unbelievable things and his ability to
throw the ball down in the field is
still special
but when i guess what i'm saying too dan
some of the guys they got in the top ten
they have far less help around them
they're capable of making a lot more
happen
on their own off schedule doing things
like that
and that's where i don't look at him as
being top tier anymore
and trust me i'm a huge big ben fan i
think he is one of those guys that's
kind of under the radar in the
conversation for one of the 10 greatest
quarterbacks of all time
i think he's that good but man some of
those guys i got my top 10 list they are
special special players yeah but you
call him underrated but you underrate
him
well i it's one year i'm talking about
he's been playing
since dinosaurs were walking the earth
okay so
this is this is one and it's it's it's a
it is weird with the fact that yes a
10-0 football team and there is no
true standout mvp candidate
but i think that speaks to the amount of
studs they have on their football team
in pittsburgh there too
i mean whether it's the two safeties
yesterday the pass rushers
to it hayward i mean you know the
receivers they got right now
there's there's a lot of guys that are
making plays to help that football team
win
games and i know the quarterback gets a
lot of that credit i don't want to take
anything away from him but uh but yeah i
just don't look them that way
yes i did uh how concerned should we be
about the ravens
um i i think there's legitimate concern
i think you're seeing without claus
campbell
and then like you know brandon williams
last the last two weeks
they get pushed around a little bit in
the run game we're not used to seeing
their defense get
physically moved around that way and
then the biggest thing
you know again we've talked the league
has caught up to the lamar jackson run
scheme
their offensive line isn't totally 100
healthy
and now we've hit to the point of okay
so what's next baltimore
who who else there's got to be something
else to the offense
it can't just be run game and mark
andrews in the pass game
that's all there is to it there's no
wide receiver involvement
there's no really creative pass schemes
there's no other element of the offense
to look at right now to go wait
as a defense i have to worry about this
guy or this thing they do
and uh that's where i worry about them
dan mclovin brings up the eagles and
carson wentz every week it's a topic
it's a national topic
it's we got to solve this it's america's
nightmare we've got to find out what's
wrong with carson wentz and the eagles
should they just go to jalen hurts
i don't think jalen from all accounts i
don't know if jalen hurts is
ready yet i think they're at the point
here where
i would dabble with more of a jalen
hurts
wrinkle in the offense on a consistent
basis i think that's where i'd probably
go more than anything
this is not a great offense it's not
great weapons
but they do need some other element and
carson wentz
i've been a defender of them it's hard
to defend it i mean it's crappy it's
careless
it's horrible pocket awareness he's
costing his team
and they can't make plays on offense so
maybe you bring a jalen hurts in kind of
like the taste of hill type of fashion
where
hey we create some plays some
schematical advantages do something like
that
it can't hurt because their offense is
sucky ducky
every week i'm sorry sucky ducky yes
sucky ducky paulie write that down got
it technical terms yeah
sucky ducky game uh more important
tonight for the rams of the buccaneers
uh i i would say the buccaneers i don't
know if i mean that's a tough one
i'm not sure it's so tough for both of
them wow um
i'd probably say the buccaneers though
because they're still kind of a work in
progress they've had the prime time
failures
things like that and uh
yeah i don't know if i wonder if i don't
know if they're concrete
sold on their plan of attack yet i hope
they stay with what they
we saw last week two tight ends
underneath the center
run the ball brady is awesome awful play
action and those deep passes
if they can do that i think they'll win
the game tonight the rams have made
five trips to the eastern time zone in
the last nine
games right that's amazing it doesn't
seem
here no it does not but they're not
going to make excuses the one thing you
could say about the rams is
they show up every week ready to compete
tough i've only seen them not show up
once in the whole mcvay era and that was
at last year's monday night game against
the baltimore ravens
other than that they're always ready to
go i do think the bucks are a tough
matchup for them
you know with the weapons big offensive
line
that's why i think you run the ball a
little bit it's a smaller defense with
the rams
and then on the other side of the ball
you would think with shaq barrett and
jpp they could stop that
zone speed sweep stuff the middle
linebackers they have and lavonte david
and devon white
they're going to be good sideline to
sideline i think they match up well i
think they win a close one
always great to see you we appreciate
your time chris thanks for joining us
bob
you the man dan say hi to everybody be
good that's chris sims
from uh football night in america and
also pro football talk live
you can see that on peacock show
precedes hours